شكرا ايمان ونواصل معكم اذا هذه النافذه
العسكريه الخاصه بالحرب الاسرائيليه على
غزه ونرحب مره اخرى بضيفنا اللواء فايز
الدويري وابدا معك اللواء فايز بما قاله
جون كيربي عن تقييم لهذه الحرب وقد سئل
غير مره في المؤتمر الصحفي عن تقييمه لما
خسرته حماس لمن بقي من حماس بعد قرابه
الثلاثه اشهر من الحرب الاسرائيليه فقال
بشكل واضح ان حماس لا تزال موجوده وانها
ستبقى كيف ت اولا لنقس في بعدين البعد
البعد العسكري الميداني
والبعد التنظيمي
والسياسي البعد الميداني موجوده من خلال
مسيره المعارك ولا يستطيع لا جون كيربي
ولا غيره ان يقول ان حماس هزمت بال في في
راس السنه اطلقت صواريخ على تل ابيب في
الثانيه الاولى وبالتالي لا تزال تقاتل
بشراسه وتوقع خسائر ومنحنى القتال هو
منحنى تصاعدي وليس
اي عكس ذلك الان نذهب الى النقطه الاخرى
ما بعد حماس والقضاء على حماس
فكره وبالتالي لا
يمكن ما بعد حماس اذا كان جون كيربي نفسه
يقول ان حماس ستبقى حماس باقيه يعني حماس
كفكره موجوده كتنظيم سياسي موجود كقوه
عسكريه موجوده يعني لم لا يمكن ان يتمكنوا
من هزيمه هذا هذا المثلث برؤوسه الثلاث
حتى في البعد العسكري لو تحدثنا فصلنا بين
حماس والقسام الجناح العسكري والجناح
السياسي والجناح السياسي مرتبط والعسكري
بخلفيه ايديولوجيه الان حتى الجناح
العسكري لحماس لم
يستطيعوا ان يقضوا عليه ولم يستطيعوا ان
يقدموا قراءه عما لق به من ضرر لانه ضراوه
المعارك تشتد اذا القدرات القتاليه موجوده
ولديهم القدره على الاستمرار في الاداء
الميداني طيب هو
قال
انه يعني الهدف الان كما قال هو ليس
القضاء على حماس لانه كما تفضلت حماس
فكره
وليس القضاء على كل فرد في حماس كما قال
تحديدا لكن القضاء على تهديد حماس والبنيه
التحتيه لحماس هل هذا الهدف يعني يعني
قابل للقياس هل هذا هدف قابل للقياس يعني
متى يمكن ان نقول انهم قضوا
على هذا هذا اجاب اجاب عليه نتنياهو ووزير
الدفاء عندما تحدثوا عن ان حماس يجب ان لا
يكون لديها القدره على تشكيل تهديد عسكري
ولا وليس لديها القدره على اطراق الصواريخ
على غزه على غلاف غزه وليس لد لديها القدر
حتى على مستوى التخطيطي لتنفذ 7 اكتوبر
جديد هذا هو المقياس هل هذا المقياس تحقق
اثنين الان بما انه حماس كتنظيم القسام
كتنظيم عسكري لا يوجد قراءه
دقيقه لدرجه الضرر التي الحقت به هو الحق
به اضرار بعد 88 يوم 89 يوم من القتال لكن
اداؤه الميداني يعني هذا توقع يعني يعني
قراءات لا يوجد لا يوجد بيانات يعني الان
فقط قتلنا وقتلنا وقتلنا ولكن نتيجه
النهائيه المعارك مستمره وبدراوى اكثر من
اكثر من بدايه المعركه اذا حماس ك جناح
مسلح موجود وكج نح سياسي موجود
و يعني اثر هذا الجناح العسكري والقدرات
القتاليه ظاهره على الخريطه لو لو كبرنا
الخريطه ظاهره على على الخريطه من الشمال
من جباليه جباليه البلد
الى الى الجنوب في خانيونس
ومرورا بالوسط كل هذه المناطق هي مناطق
اجتماعيه يعني المناطق التي تم الاعلان عن
السيطره عليها وتم الحديث عن الانتقال الى
المرحله الثالثه وتم الحديث عن سحب القوات
هذه المنطقه التي نشاهدها وهي منطقه صغيره
تقريبا
اي اقل من ثلث يعني اقل من ثلث او 37 35
بال من مساحه قطاع غزه هذه استخدم فيها
ثلاثه فرق الان ابقي على اربعه الويه
تقاتل في منطقه جبل الريس والشعف والتفاح
وغرب الشجاعيه والزاويه الجنوبيه الشرقيه
من جباليا هذه المنطقه هذه المنطقه
المحدوده المساحه هذه الان يقاتل بها
اربعه الويه وقتال ظاري وبدا يتراجع من
كافه النقاط باستثناء انه القتال متحرك في
جبل الريس يتقدم ويجبر على التراجع اذا
ذهبنا الى المنطقه الوسطى اه نذهب الى
المنطقه الوسطى اذا هنالك في مخيم البري
المنطقه المسط الوسطى الان في ار اربع
اربع ان سيرات البريج المغازي الزوايده
هذه المنطقه يوجد فيها
فرقتين يوجد فيها الفرقه 36 زائد لوائين
يقاتل فيها في هذه المساحه محدوده وحتى
هذه اللحظه دخلوا الى الاجزاء الجنوبيه من
البريج والى الاجزاء الغربيه ولمسافات
محدوده جدا واجبروا على التراجع في الجناح
الجنوبي ولا يزال القتال موجود في الجناح
الشرقي الصيرات بدا الهجوم تقريبا منذ منذ
الامس بالزو بالاتجاه الشرقي لانه احدثوا
ثغره ما بين البريج وما بين الصيرات و
عملوا احاطه على الزاويه الشماليه الغربيه
لمهاجمه سيرات وفي تماس مع المغازي اذا لا
يوجد اي تقدم يعتد به لا بل الهجوم
الرئيسي من الجهه الشرقيه تم اجباره الى
الرجوع الى منطقه السياج اذا ذهبنا لىى
المنطقه الجنوبيه نعم نذهب الى الجنوب الى
خان يونس وهناك منطقه خان يونس الان
القتال يتركز بصوره رئيسيه شرق خان يونس
شرق شارع صلاح الدين ولكن ليس في خان يونس
في اطراف خان يونس ساتي على ذكره لانه
يعني لا من فصل المعركه الى جزئين الان
الجزء الشرقي لو سمحت سلام بس تاشر لنا
شارع صلاح الدين حتى يكون واضح للمشاهد
شرق هذا الشارع القوات في نسق وهي المره
الاولى تستخدم نظام الانساق الان يوجد في
النسق الاول سبعه الويه مدعومه بثلاثه
كتائب نخبه ويوجد في النسق الثاني لوائين
مدعوم بكتيبه مظليين اذا جمعنا الاجمالي
حوالي 8 الويه زائد كتيبه في هذه المنطقه
يعني كم فرد كم فرد مقاتل الان تختلف من
لواء للواء يعني اللواء يتراوح في بعض
الحالات عندك الوي 3500 لى 4500 عندك لواء
جفعاتي في بعض الحالات يكون 10 كتائب في
حالات اخرى يكون يعني لا توجد ارقام ثابته
لكن نتحدث عن الوي بهذا الحجم ومعظم لا
يقل عن 3 ال جندي ا اكثر سيكون اكثر الان
حتى في بني سيله في الطرف الشمالي منها
اجبروا على الرجوع بصوره كامله وانتقلوا
الى الهجوم من الجهه الجنوبيه يعني حتى
هذا الكم الهائل الذي اصلا هو سبب مشكله
لذاته في اداره المعركه بدات الخسائر
كبيره جدا واصبح وهذا هو الذي طرح السؤال
الذي طرحته ذكرته سلام قبل قليل عن القائد
السابق الذي تحدث عن اخطاء استراتيجيه هل
العدد الكبير هو من ضمن الاخطاء استرا
استخدام قوه زائده عن قدره الارض على
اتساعها وبالتالي اصبحت اهداف سهله خاصه
انه المقاتل معظمهم في في
الانفاق من اي فتحه نفق يخرج يجد قريب منه
اهداف امامه وبالتالي هذا ما نشدنا في
الفيديوهات في خان يونس يحاول ان يطوق خان
يونس ويدخل من المنطقه الشماليه لانه تقدم
من منطقه القراره لكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم
لم ينجح في اي من المحاولتين لدينا ايضا
فيديوهات اليوم اسقاط طائره من طراز هيرمس
900 طبعا هي مسيره
اسرائيليه لها مواصفات خاصه دخلت الخدمه
عام
2014 تحلق لمده 40 ساعه متواصله
اي تستخدم في عمليات الاغتيال
وعمليات القص يعني تستخدم في عمليات الا
الواجب الاول لها الواجب الاستطلاع مزوده
بكاميرات عاليه الدقه و تقدم معلومات على
مدار الساعه
وال هي تستطيع حمل متفجرات او صواريخ ل
300 غرام وبالتالي هي تستخدم في ادوار
قتاليه هجوميه وعمليات استهداف وتستخدم في
عمليات الاستطلاع وهي تقريبا تعتبر
الطائره رقم اثنين من حيث الجوده والتقنيه
والتجهيز في التقنيات
في جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يعني طائره
كبيره ليست طائره كبيره وال القسام تحدث
انه تم اسقاطها بصاروخ حوالي طن يعني وزنه
حوالي طن نعم هي بالتالي يعني يبدو انها
لم تكن تطير على الارتفاع الاعلى الحد
الاعلى لانه في بعض المصادر تحدثوا انها
تصل الى تستطيع الطيران لمده 30 ساعه وعلى
ارتفاع 3000 قدم هنا ذكر 100000 قدم في
مصادر اخرى قرات 30 الف قدم اسقطت بصاروخ
ارض جو اسقطت بصاروخ ارض جو معناته كانت
تطير على ارتفاع منخفض لانه الصواريخ التي
تستخدم لم يحدد هل هو سام 7 ام سم 18
وبالتالي 18 تقريبا 3500 متر و7500 متر
فكان التطير على مستوى منخفض فيما يتعلق
يعني مجريات المعركه الميدانيه لدينا ايضا
خبر عن استخدام روبوتات هذا هو الروبوت من
جانب جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
لخداع المقاتلين في المقاومه للاعتقاد
لانه يصدر اصوات دبابات واصوات مدرعات
واصوات جنود احيانا ربما
ليقنع بان هنالك اهدافا فيخرجوا من
الانفاق لكن ما ما الذي يحدث حينما يخرج
من الانفاق نحنا راينا النتائج ليس يعني
الان اللي تحدث عنها القسام انه كشف
الخدعه اذا معناته الخدعه لم تنطلي عليه
هذا اللي هو جي اف اكس جي اف اكس الذي
يصدر اصوات كصوت الدبابه
واصوات اصوات الرمايه لكن الاسوا منه
الاخر اللي هو جاجوار وهو روبوت ذكي
جدا مركب عليها اجهزه
استشعار رشاش
7.62 يتحرك ذاتيا ومن خلال اجهزه
الاستشعار يتغلب على المعيقات وبالتالي هو
اصبح كانه قوه قوه ناريه مقاتله متحركه
فبالتالي هذا الاستخدام للروبوت جاجوار قد
يكون له الاول لخداع المقاتل للخروج ولكن
هذا يستطيع ان يستهدف المقاتل جرب
الاسرائيليون من قبل مساله خداع المقاومه
بعمليات توغل وهميه وكانت النتيجه ان
المقاومه كشفت يعني ماذا يخبرنا ذلك عن
قراءه المقاومه لج هذه قبل
بدء المعركه البريه كان هناك اي محاوله
توغل
وا اقرن او تلت قصف جوي مكثف جدا كانه
القصف التمهيدي الذي يشير الى ال بدايه
الهجوم واندفعت بعض الاليات بمسافات
محدوده لكن القسام لم يتعامل معها لانه
كان لديه معلومات موثوقه بان هذا هجوم
تضليلي وبالتالي لم تخرج ولم اي تتعامل
معه وعادت القوه ادراجها لانه الخدعه كشفت
وبالتالي هذا يدل على ان لديه جهاز
استخبارات على درجه عاليه من الكفاءه شكرا
جزيلا لواء فايز دور الخبر العسكري
والاستراتيجي